lady gaga's dog walker is in the
hospital following a shooting that took
place while he was walking the 34 year
old singer's dogs on wednesday night
now a source tells et the singer is
offering a 500
000 reward for the return of her dogs no
questions
asked the lapd tells et that the
shooting took place
in los angeles at 9 40 p.m on sierra
bonita avenue
and that the shooter was seen fleeing
the scene in a white sedan
two of gaga's three french bulldogs
gustav and
koji were stolen while a third asia
managed to escape and was later
recovered by police
the weapon used was a semi-automatic
handgun and has not been recovered
the suspect is currently at large the
dog walker who a source confirms to e.t
is lady gaga's friend ryan fisher was
walking the grammy winner's dogs while
she's in italy filming the movie gucci
now a source tells et that gaga is
offering a 500 000
reward for the return of her dogs using
the email koji and gustav
gmail.com the source also tells et that
fisher is expected to fully recover